en l'état est-ce que vous votez stectte
non c'est clair comme réponseétique très
cl elle est inacceptable cette version
de C non parce que on va pas raconter
d'histoire aux Français le le but de ce
texte quand il est sorti quand général
Darmanin l'a présenté cé un texte
d'équilibre qui qui essayé de pousser
les curseurs aussi bien à droite qu'à
gauche sur tout ce qu'on pouvait faire
de manière crédible c'est-à-dire
efficace qu'on puisse faire là il y a
des mesures que le scénat a mis en place
qui sont d'une efficacité totale et qui
n'apporteront rien de plus qui sont que
des postures politiciennes on reparlera
je pense de alors que vos alliés
Renaissance François patrina au Sénat
les quelques sénateurs modem les voter
alors mais parce que le Sénat c'est le
Sénat nous c'est l'Assemblée nationale
c'est différent il vous choque ce vote
de vos camarades bah sur la me par
exemple oui on est on est
considérablement choqué je je vous le
confirme même s'il y a des peut-être des
améliorations à faire sur la me on ne
supprime pas la me c'est c'est c'est un
nonsens à la fois budgétaire et
sanitaire donc je vois pas l'intérêt
honnêtement ce qui a été voté au Sénat
ça change rien dans les faits donc
onance pas et il y a quand même si on
veut être assez didactique il y a trois
sortes de
travailleurs immigrés en France il y a
ceux qui ont euh des des papiers des
cartes de séjour qui sont renouvelables
et tous dans nos circonscriptions alorsx
ils sont là légalement sur le territoire
ils ont une carte de séjour renouvelable
et tous dans circonscrition que soit Yan
Boucard soit Boris Vallot tous les ans
on intervient auprès des préfectures
pour les renouvellements de cartes de
séjour des gens qui sont là depuis 10 15
ans qui sont obligés de renouveler leur
cadre de séjour à chaque fois ça c'est
une hypocrisie total on peut pas laisser
ces gens-là avec une épée de Damocles
au-dessus de la tête se dire que jamais
ils n'auront de papier définitifs alors
qu'ils sont intégré ça c'est pas
l'article 3 non c'est pas l'article 3
mais pour que ce soit clair dans la tête
non mais ce sont aussi des étrangers
des gens faisons le situation
irrégulière la deuxème catégorie c'est
ceux qui n'ont pas de papier mais qui
ont un contrat de travail déjà moi faut
qu'on m'explique comment on arrive à
faire ça mais ils ont un contrat de
travail ils payent des cotisations Boris
Valo l'a répéteré il payent des
cotisations retraite dont ils ne verront
jamais la couleur et ces gens-là pareil
ils cotisent ils participent à à la vie
de la nation et pareil épé d'amocl ils
ne savent pas de quoi demain sera fait
c'est pas un traitement humain enfin
honnêtement j'ai beau ne pas être
socialiste Boris ballot le sait très
bien je suis homodème c'est pas un
traitement humain après qu'on regarde la
situation attendez après qu'on regarde
la situation de ces gens-là dans le
détail pour ne pas accorder la
régularisation à tout le monde parce
qu'il faut quand même qu'on fasse
attention ça c'est autre chose mais on
peut pas juste balayer en disant non ces
gens-là on les régularis pas et le 3è
les 3è catégories de de de de
travailleurs immigrés ce sont ceux qui
malheureusement pour eux malheureusement
pour eux participent parce qu'on ne
dénonce pas assez en France cette espèce
de marchandisation d'esclavagisme
moderne qui fait qu'on va employer des
gens au noir d'accord et ça c'est juste
scandaleux ces gens n'ont aucun droit
donc que ces gens-là puissent aller en
préfecture en disant mais monsieur voilà
j'ai travaillé pendant tant de temps les
deux dernières années à avec ou pas
enfin en général des fausses des fausses
feuilles fiches de paye moi je suis
d'accord parce que ça permettra aussi de
dénoncer ceux qui participent à cette
traite ce que j'appelle l'esclavagisme
moderne dans le monde du travail et ça
c'est aussi intolérable voilà trois
catégories de travailleurs immigrés
trois façons de réag je comprends que
vous voulez revenir c'est votre droit le
plus absolu de parlementaire c'est le
sens même du débat à l'article initial
l'aide médicale d'État Bruno milen il
faut absolument la rétablir mais c'est
une enfin c'est une aberration cette
suppression d'abord c'est unepocreusie
totale parce qu'on supprime la me mais
on maintient la mu c'est c'est l'IDE
médicale d'urgence enfin limité aux
maladies graves et douleurs aigu vous
imaginez si on avait pas eu la sagesse
du gouvernement vous imaginez si vous
avez pas eu si vous aviez pas eu la me
pendant la crise du covid non mais les
gens se rendent compte ou pas il faut
dire la vérité aux gens tous c les
immigrés dont parlait Boris qui ont eu
des tragets pour arriver jusqu'en France
qui sont épouvantables certains viennent
avec des mal laad infectieuse et il faut
les soigner tout de suite pour éviter
les risques de pour eux déjà pour éviter
les
risques de pandémie monsieur Boucard je
ne vous ai pas interrompu donc
laissez-moi terminer laame son avantage
c'est qu'on sait la chiffrer 1,2
milliards 1,2 milliards ok vous
supprimez la me vous croyez pour autant
que les médecins ils l'ont dit sur tous
les tons le ministre de la Santé l'a dit
aussi c'est hipocrate vous croyez que
les médecins vont arrêter de soigner les
gens mais non mais alors tout ça va
disparaître non pas dans les li mais
dans les budgets des hôpitaux qui sont
déjà exangles et au final de toute façon
c'est le c'est le citoyen qui Pera donc
arrêtons arrêtons de faire croire aux
gens qu'en supprimant la me on va
arrêter l'appel d' vous ne réécrirez pas
Clement d'Hippocrate pour avoir les voix
de LR j'ai bien compris qu'on regarde
attentivement ceux qui viennent faire
entre guillemets du tourisme médical
pour se soigner en France s'il y a
vraiment une raison valable ou pas ça
c'est une chose donc ça c'est le panier
de soins que vous voulez bien réduire le
panier soin à transiger voilà maisêtre
cohérence monsieur Valot moi je
comprends pas pourquoi on donne le
panier de soins qu'au bout de 3 mois par
exemple et pourquoi le panier de soins
complet est à 9 mois allez qui veut
répondre B à mon sens le panier soin il
doit être donné jusqu'à ce qu'on
obtienne ou pas son autorisation de
rester sur le territoire voilà il y a
des débats qu'on ne peut pas perd par
l'Assemblée nationale quand on est dans
la majorité il y a des débats qu'on peut
perdre si on explique la justesse des
mesures qu'on a mises si on trouve le
parfait équilibre dans ce texte moi je
veux bien être battu parce que les
Français verront les hypocrisies d'un
côté comme de l'autre